I'm sure I'm not alone I'm thinking the
Battle of the Blackwater was the best
episode of Blackwater was plumb I was
very excited that I did get to write it
even though it that he didn't include us
many of my favorite characters so I
missed any chance to uh to write about
you know like Aria for example who's
totally absolutely Danny
the episode was just focused on the
Blackwater but that gave it a certain
unity which I think made it work very
well
some part about writing either courses
you know killing your children I I knew
him for you I don't like to kill or lose
you know good good Vince and the Battle
of Blackwater as it appears in the book
would have cost the budget of a Peter
Jackson film I mean I was very happy
that so many of you guys out there liked
it so much because we didn't have to
lose a lot I mean we lost the chain
right away that was like the first great
ability and I think okay the three
boards throwing the implement and we
can't do so we lost that but we managed
to keep a lot of good stuff and the
Wildfire which really made it and then
with the the plum on top of the pudding
there we got we got new immortals who
directed it was a amazing amazing
director who had never done television
before and came in really at the last
moment when they originally scheduled
director had a and a family emergency
and the job he did was it was just
phenomenal for me are the things that
surprised us as readers so much from the
very beginning with bran Gaston
the window to the red wedding to all
kinds of other things that hit us full
square in the face but they ate you that
way or did you know I knew all those
things ahead of time those those things
were all carefully planned or as
carefully planned well you know it's a
question of what all right
rephrase this carefully well I say I
knew them all ahead of time well we had
to find ahead of plan I mean when I
began there's a new nothing idea though
it came out of the blue but at some
point we're where the book was really
starting to shape those pieces fell into
shape but a lot of other things have
come in I mean I originally saw this as
a trilogy and now of the trilogy so but
the principle turning blocks the
principle set pieces and the big
shocking moments I I know a lot of
people and I'm suspect you mean a lot of
people including myself read the books
he is so messing with her expectations
you know and do you ever just as a
writer who had been in the business a
long time never said yourself I am gonna
mess with these absolutely adorable
child I'm going to make everybody love
it in five pages I mean I long before I
was a writer I was a reader I was a
reader I was electric television those
laughter movies and all these things and
I still do I love to read I love fiction
I love movies I love television shows
and the one thing that I hate more than
anything else is predictability I hate
reading a novel where you read the first
chapter and you know exactly how it's
going to end and then you know if you do
plow on and read the rest of it it does
exactly what you thought it was going to
do and there's never there's never a
surprise in it
I don't like that in movies I don't like
that in television shows and it bores me
and we've already I mean I hate to think
if you count how many books I've read
Emily movies I've seen Emily television
shows like what from life diamonds and
true for all of you so I think you have
to shake up the rules a little and and
you know readers weight or viewers awake
and take them in places that they that
they don't expect to to go and that's
hard it's very hard you know what my
first experience on television writing
was on the revival to Twilight
under the mid-80s and I grew up watching
the original pilots of Rod Serling show
and so many of you here at ascension
event remember to Rod Serling show and
in Rod Serling show was was famous for
its
twist endings you all know that right
burgess Meredith breaks his glasses
and Francis is a mannequin you know the
girl that we think is getting made the
ugly girl is actually beautiful and the
beautiful people are ugly and all that
wonderful wonderful episodes in 1959 in
1960 so we're back in 1987 here where
we're 85 86 87 we're doing the new
Twilight don't know we got CBS all over
our ass here or a network saying why
don't your shows have twist endings like
the original people want twist endings
and what a problem is that the audience
of 1986 or sophisticated in the audience
in 1959 they could see all these twist
endings come a mile away you know yeah
we we tried to do a remake of the
mannequin episode you know we did
remakes and everybody knew that you know
the lead character was a mannequin we
had full anybody for an instant so it's
harder to be unpredictable because we've
all seen so many television shows and so
many movies and we've seen these
so what I do strive for it I don't say I
always succeed but I can strive for it I
think it makes for more involving
entertainment I don't need it the way I
want you think I would say this just
picks up on something I mentioned a
moment ago when I was talking about
brand in the first book in five pages
you make this love which is something
that you do consistently be it love or
any other feeling that you seem to want
us to have it I think specifically at
some of the prologue and epilogue I
think to one of the books for even
Genizah character we hadn't known before
within within paragraphs know who this
person is man and woman we have a
feeling about this person we understand
them we've invested them that to me is
someone who has written in my life seems
like a magical power and I wanted to
know if you could say just talking about
craft for a second if you have
techniques to do that if you if there's
something that you know that you can
share with us now about how to create
these characters so vividly and so
quickly well I'm not I use a very tight
third-person view point structure you
know as a writer you have a variety of
ways that you can you can tell a story
you can use first person of course and
I've done that occasionally and in my
life with a characters actually saying I
did this I did that that has the effect
of someone who is actually telling a
story and when people tell story
sometimes they lie so that could be that
can be sort of interesting but you can
also do third-person objective
third-person omniscient where you know
your god they're looking down and you're
just describing what's happened or
you're entering the minds of any
character well you know one moment
you're in the waitresses mind the next
one we're in the customers mind the next
one we're in a cookbooks line that's on
vision through point or your God you
know what everyone's thinking or
objective where you don't enter anyone's
mind and this is a current favorite I
think of a lot of literary writers will
you just describe actually what's
happening you never enter in any of
those sports obviously I don't use any
techniques I pick a single void point
character and I go heavily inside their
thoughts so you not only hear what
they're saying but you hear what they
are thinking but only the one person you
know I don't like on mission because
we're not God we don't experience
stories that way we experience stories
through our single point of eyes
you know I'm looking you're all looking
at us here and I'm looking out at you
and we have very different viewpoint
things you know if suddenly a giant
cockroach started crawling up the wall
behind us some of you might react there
and I would have no idea what was
happening why are these people looking
so strangely and as you know and that's
the way you and beings live life and all
that and at the same time for making you
intimate to the characters for once I
think illegally to get who they are and
what's important to them and that's why
I don't like the strictly objective
viewpoint where we just say well what I
said what I do which is much more almost
a cinematic technique I mean a something
written in third-person objective is
what the camera sees because in what
you're doing in to a voiceover which is
tremendously clumsy you you you can't
hear the the ideas of character so for
that we depend on some clues that the
directors put in and that the actors
supply I can actually write you know yes
you can trust me II lied how do you do
that on whose unstated sue yeah